bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur arte france on l'a entendu dans
son discours hier soir emmanuel macron
redoute que l'afghanistan redevienne un
sanctuaire du terrorisme le retour des
talibans et le vide laissé par les
occidentaux ne donne-t-il pas un nouveau
souffle au terrorisme international
c'est évidemment ce qui est inquiétant
c'est que l'arrivée des talibans le
retour des taliban plus exactement va
apparaître clairement dans l'idéologie
de l'ensemble des groupes terroristes
islamistes divers et variés de l'afrique
jusqu'à l'asie comme un véritable succès
est à l'image de ce qui s'était passé
avec le retrait américain d'irak en 2014
on voit bien que le message est lancé
quelque part à d'autres groupes qui
voudraient aussi à un moment ou un autre
et susciter un califat ou s'emparer d'un
pays pour y imposer la charia et
l'extrême charia en réalité sur
l'ensemble de ce territoire tout comme
ce qui s'était passé en irak et ce qui
s'est ensuite passé en syrie le succès
des talibans évidemment va s'inscrire
dans un récit de longue durée comme
c'est le cas déjà depuis des décennies
en afghanistan qui a toujours été une
terre de régénérescence et de
résurrection du djihadisme vous voyez
bien il ya d'anciens barons des talibans
on a retrouvé vingt ans après sur
d'autres terrains de conflit que ce soit
au sahel à boko haram avec boko haram
que ce soit en algérie lors de la
décennie noire donc on voit bien que
l'afghanistan est un maillon
incontournable dans cette dans cette
situation et que tout dépendra également
de ce que voudront faire inviter les
talibans parce que l'on sait qu'ils sont
relativement tolérant avec al qaïda pour
le moment mais qu'ils sont en lutte
depuis des années avec avec des chais
l'état islamique qui avait créé un semis
khalifa en 2015 la ville accord hassan
et qu' on n'est pas du tout sûr que ça
me sera possible que les tensions
augmentent au sein même de l'afghanistan
mais après les projets entre les deux
organisations sont relativement
différentes autres discours en celui de
joe by dane qui campe il est campé hier
sur ses positions la toujours beaucoup
entendu sur la défense des droits de
l'homme et lire dans son discours il a
déclaré que les droits de l'homme
devaient être au coeur de la diplomatie
américaine mais est-ce que c'est pas un
peu ironique quand on se rappelle de ces
images terribles d'afghans qui ont
envahi le tarmac de l'aéroport de kaboul
pour tenter de fuir
c'est évidemment un voeu pieux est en
réalité je trouve une scène une certaine
part de naïveté job de joe biden qui
fait une pirouette puisque fin mais il
nous annonçait dans un certain nombre de
tweets que et l'état et l'armée afghane
était tout à fait capable de prendre en
charge le pays est en réalité va petit à
petit on avait de jour en jour son
discours relativement glissé c'est à
dire qu'au delà de la fermeté il a fini
par rendre responsable directement
l'état et l'armée afghane qui n'ont pas
voulu combattre ce qui n'est évidemment
pas tout à fait faux puisque la présence
américaine n'est pas juste uniquement a
fustigé sur 20 ans et du coup on en
déduire que c'est un échec total
donald trump avait quelque part raison
quand il expliquait que tout cet argent
qui avaient été déversés pour la
sécurité au pakistan n'avait pas été
extraordinairement efficace il en a été
malheureusement de même avec
l'afghanistan et toutes ces élites
corrompues qui pendant vingt ans n'ont
pas été capables de construire un état
fort viable structuré et avec une
capacité d'une armée afghane et une
gouvernance qui soit digne de ce nom et
qui puisse protéger évidemment les
avenants à un moment je pense aussi que
les américains sont dans leurs limites
au delà du message parfois un peu
universelle est naïf de vouloir défendre
les droits de l'homme partout sur sur la
terre si effectivement et dubaï donna
raison l'état afghan n'a pas été capable
les avenants évidemment malheureusement
démissionner complètement livrés à
eux-mêmes que les états unis peuvent
encore voir enrôlant l'abbé naissant
en afghanistan ou ailleurs c'est la
véritable question de ce que les états
unis peuvent faire dans une intervention
extérieure depuis le vietnam depuis la
somalie par exemple avec la chute de
mogadiscio en 1993
on voit bien ses images tout à fait
symbolique de cet hélicoptère quittant
kaboul avec les ressortissants de
l'ambassade de l'ambassade américaine je
crois que comme dans d'autres situations
de conflit on est dans une situation où
le évidemment va capter d'autres
d'autres pays d'autres d'autres états
qui auront un intérêt évidemment avec
l'afghanistan je pense évidemment à la
chine et à la russie après c'est de la
pure realpolitik comme on la constate au
quotidien c'est à dire que s'il y a un
intérêt d'un certain nombre de pays à
normaliser des relations avec les
talibans et vous les voyez bien même
dans le discours de john hayes dernière
il n'est pas du tout exclu à un moment
de le faire comme certains pays l'ont
fait avec bachar el-assad par exemple
après des années de guerre civile je
crois que certains pays le feront et ce
qu'ils auront la capacité de faire
pression sur les talibans pour respecter
mettre en place les droits de l'homme ça
c'est une véritable question est ce
qu'il ya beaucoup de communication
politique de la part des talibans pour
essayer de se montrer plus normalisé ou
dédiaboliser je crois qu'il ya aussi
beaucoup de bluff parce que l'objectif
premier et dernier des talibans c'est
véritablement d'instaurer un état
islamique sur l'afghanistan et a priori
uniquement sur l'afghanistan je ne crois
pas qu'il y ait du coup véritablement de
par la nature même du projet depuis plus
de vingt ans de véritables demi mesure
dans la manière avec laquelle ils vont
malheureusement s'y prendre une à la
question sébastien boussois est-ce que
vous pensez que les talibans sont à même
de gérer ganis temps je crois qu'ils
avaient créé et produit un pareil tu as
depuis plusieurs depuis plusieurs années
ils prétendent pouvoir le faire il
serait difficile et peut-être assez
ironique de condamner leurs projets tout
en condamnant leur idéologie et leurs
moyens d'action puisque ni d'étape dans
ni les américains ni personne ne réussit
à faire de quoi que ce soit de ce pays
depuis la chute de najibullah qui avait
du dernier président afghan communiste
qui avait été clairement assassiné par
les talibans en 1996 personne mais
absolument personne n'est parvenu à
structurer un état qui soit 1 et à
sécuriser et qui puisse permettre
d'apporter le meilleur aux afghans je ne
sais pas si les talibans seront capables
mais en tout cas ce qu'ils peuvent faire
passer comme message c'est de
l'austérité
rigueur malheureusement évidemment de
l'extrémisme religieux et et fanatique
mais peut-être aussi un certain nombre
d'afghans ont de la sympathie pour les
talibans parce qu'ils sont surtout
ulcéré et à bout de la manière dont ce
pseudo étape dans depuis l'arrivée des
américains était censé apporter sécurité
paix et je dirais prospérité économique
alors qu'il n'a été que gabegie et
corruption de la part des élites afghane
pendant des années qui ont également
détourné énormément d'argent qui est
parti dans un certain nombre de pays du
golfe depuis y depuis des années merci
beaucoup sébastien boussois pour eux
toutes ces précisions je vous rappelle
que vous êtes docteur en sciences
politiques les chercheurs sur le
moyen-orient merci à vous